PAUL KINLAN: Hi everyone.
Welcome to Mobile
Web Thursdays.
I'm Paul Kinlan.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And I'm
Jake Archibald.
Thank you for tuning in.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
That's right, actually.
That was actually pretty good.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
I'm getting the hang
of this TV thing.
PAUL KINLAN: He's been
planning that for
about two hours now.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh,
it's very good.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I'm very
happy with myself.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
So we're also known as
the Chuckle Brothers.
And today we're going to be
talking about Mobile Web
Performance.
Right?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yes.
PAUL KINLAN: So shall
we get started?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
Why not?
One of the things that really
bugs me when people talk about
mobile performance is they're
either treating mobiles as
this special thing--
And mobiles really aren't
that special, right?
OK, they're touch.
But touch isn't just mobile.
We've got Chromebook
Pixel here.
That's got touch.
These Windows devices
are the same.
PAUL KINLAN: Is that touch?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: No.
It is a Mac.
It's not touch.
You could say, oh,
cellular data.
That's mobile.
But it's not.
Because once again, people run
their laptops off MiFis,
things like that.
And sometimes your phone is
quite often on WiFi data.
In fact, some small devices
like your Nexus 7s or your
iPod Touches, they don't have
cellular data on all
models of them do.
Mobiles are really just smaller
and less power than a
main desktop machine.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Wouldn't
you say?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
It's kind of interesting.
I think what's starting to lead
us to what we're trying
to talk about today is that
we were at Educomm--
It was Educomm, wasn't it?-- and
I think Facebook said that
they noticed a significant drop
off of interaction based
off the change of frame rate
between 60 frames a second
down to 30 frames a second.
And the slower and the jankier
the experience was actually
inside the application, the less
engagement that they got,
which got us thinking about--
well, we've been doing it for a
little while now-- but we're
starting to push more about
this jank-free--
I've got to say that correctly,
because I can never
say that quite right--
experience where you'll
get 60 frames a second
experience on mobile.
And a lot of people
think you can't.
We think you can.
And I think we're going to try
and show you today some of the
gotchas, the how-tos,
the wherefores.
What else can we say?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Well, if you
serve just a lump of HTML to a
phone, it works.
It works quite well, and
it runs quite fast.
So saying how to make something
faster in mobile
isn't really the right
thing to say.
We're saying how not to make it
slow, because it's fast to
begin with.
As developers, we're the
ones who make it slow.
So I don't swear very
much as a person.
Is that fair to say?
PAUL KINLAN: No.
You do.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: OK.
Maybe I do.
But I've been told that--
PAUL KINLAN: He's worried,
by the way.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: --I'm really
not allowed to.
And when you're told you're
not allowed--
PAUL KINLAN: Beep.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: --my brain's
like the back of a
teenager's math book.
It's absolutely disgusting
right now.
And when you're told you
are one syllable away
from losing your job--
So you're going to
help, right?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
As I say, we've got this
preemptive beep machine.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So you're
going to beep.
PAUL KINLAN: I'm
We haven't got a proper one,
so I have to go beep.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: OK.
I get a twitch in my eye
when I'm about--
PAUL KINLAN: I've
been watching.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: --to
drop a word bomb.
So watch out for that.
PAUL KINLAN: On that note--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Actually,
shut the fridge door.
See?
I thought I would let
you in there.
That was a test.
I wasn't actually
going to swear.
PAUL KINLAN: Dude, I know.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But
you missed.
I thought you were going
to be here for me.
PAUL KINLAN: I'm going to be
preemptive when I know you are
going to do it.
And I knew you weren't
going to do it, so I
wasn't going to do it.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Well,
we'll see.
We'll see if I've got a job
at the end of this.
Let's take a look
at an example.
All that stuff I was saying
before about mobiles not being
special, we're going to look
at a case where they are
special just to prove
myself wrong.
So if we can take a look at
what's on my desktop machine
and look at the first
demo we have here--
PAUL KINLAN: Can I just say
before we start, we have a
Moderator where people can
actually ask questions.
We should have the link
on the screen
somewhere at the bottom.
Yeah.
So you can go and ask us
questions, and we'll answer
them at the end of the show.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Let's do that.
PAUL KINLAN: So shall we get
doing what you're going to do?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
So I'm in JSbin for
our first demo.
So what we have here
is a series of devs
all of the same class.
It's a really dumb
and simple demo.
And the JavaScript here, all
that's going to do is it's
going to loop through all
of those elements.
It's going to give
them a hue value.
It's going to cycle through all
360 and create this kind
of rainbow effect here.
Now when you click on them using
ClickListener here, it's
going to swap that to the
opposite side of the hue.
So what we get is click,
click, click,
and it will go back.
So that's how it works
on desktop.
It's really fast.
But let's have a look at
how it works on mobile.
So if we can switch to
the mobile view--
This is running on
a Nexus 7, but it
runs the same on phones.
So here it is.
As you can see, it's
scrolling.
We get pinch zoom.
That's fine.
And I tap on it, and
it changes color.
But it's really, really slow.
And I was saying before that
mobiles are not as fast as
desktop machines, but they're
not that slow.
Painting a rectangle different
colors is not really a task
any device should
struggle with
So what's happening here is
click events actually run with
a 300 millisecond
delay on mobile.
Now I'll show you why
that happens.
If we have a look at
Google Moderator--
Google Moderator is a site that
isn't really optimized
well for mobile, so no points
to us there for that--
Apple came up with this
interaction where they would
start with the screen
zoomed out.
And if you wanted to zoom in to
a part of it, you could use
a pinch zoom, but you
could also do this.
You could double-tap.
You could double-tap it.
It zooms in.
And all of the others mobile
devices have copied that.
And this is our problem.
Because how do we know if you're
going to double-tap
when you tap?
Well, the only way we can do
that is by just having a
little wait and seeing
what you do next.
And if you don't tap again,
that's not a double-tap.
It's said that if you want
something to seem instant it
has to happen within 100
milliseconds of the user
clicking the thing.
And with 300 milliseconds added
to start of that, you're
three times over budget
before you've run any
JavaScript at all.
But we can use JavaScript
to work around that.
PAUL KINLAN: I know some of the
guys who are working on
the touch side of things are
trying to improve this even
for normal viewports.
Because if you can detect that
you're at full zoom, for
instance, then you're not
going to try and do the
double-tap in.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yep.
PAUL KINLAN: And there's
questions about whether we can
optimize that experience so that
we don't have to actually
have a viewport if you don't
want to have a viewport, and
all this type stuff.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
And if there's anything else you
want to spoil ahead of me
getting around to it--
PAUL KINLAN: Am I
spoiling things?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: --that's fine.
Tell you what--
PAUL KINLAN: You've got all
the lines down here.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: --I could leave
if you just want to read
from my notes.
That's fine.
PAUL KINLAN: Well, there's
something about the FT
[INAUDIBLE].
JAKE ARCHIBALD: No, don't
talk about the FT.
PAUL KINLAN: You told
me to read ahead.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: You nearly
made me do one of those
job-ending noises.
OK.
Actually, let's take a look at
the desktop machine, and I can
show the code for this one.
It's number three.
So this code looks exactly--
PAUL KINLAN: That's
a nice code.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: --the same.
It's a lovely code.
It's my favorite.
I spent at least a few minutes
writing it yesterday.
So here's the difference.
This one isn't click.
It's touchend.
So it's using a touch event.
It doesn't work on
the desktop.
You would have to add a click
event in as well.
If we can switch to the phone,
you can see the difference it
makes here.
So I can scroll around
the page.
And if I tap, it changes.
And as you see, it's happening
instantly.
So we've got a real performance
boost out of that.
This is on Chrome for Android.
We'll take a look at
the same thing
running in another browser.
I should point out this
is not my Nexus.
I'm not a fitness fanatic, and
I wasn't planning on having a
nipple slip this early on
in the presentation.
PAUL KINLAN: It's my Nexus.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Is
that your Nexus?
PAUL KINLAN: It's my test one.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I'm just going
to grab him by the nipple and
fling him away.
Excellent.
So let's go into Firefox, and
let's have a look at the same
URL and site.
In fact, do I have
it prepared?
Oh, that's lovely.
So this is the same thing.
We're using the touch event.
And so if I tap, it works.
But as I scroll, when I let
go it still getting
that touch end event.
And this is not Firefox
doing it wrong.
In fact, the default old Android
browser does the same.
iOS Safari does the same.
In fact, Chrome's kind of the
one doing it different.
And it's not going
against the spec.
It's just unspeced behavior.
It doesn't say whether a touch
sequence should be cancelled
if a scroll starts.
PAUL KINLAN: Does it happen
in Safari as well?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yes,
in Safari on iOS.
Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Does it match
Chrome's behavior, or does it
match Firefox's?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It matches
Firefox's behavior.
PAUL KINLAN: It's actually
something that we're doing
inside the browser ourselves.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
Chrome is the exception.
By doing what I would
say would be to the
right thing to do--
Once you've started doing a
scroll, then I don't want to
hear about the touch, because
the browser's taken over
handling touch events.
But yeah, no one's actually
breaking the spec.
It's unspecified behavior.
We do have a fix for this
in the form of the
Pointer Events spec.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
It's something Microsoft came
up with and is now being
worked through w3.
And that explicitly says--
and we'll include
a link to this--
that if you do a zoom or a pan
or a scroll then you get touch
cancel events, and you
won't get a touchend
or a pointer end.
It's not touch.
So that's something for the
future, but it's doesn't
really help us now,
unfortunately.
And I think we're much more
concerned with now.
PAUL KINLAN: So do you know if
there's many sites that are
using touchend for this?
Is it mainly--?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: No.
Because most people find out
that it's going to cause that
kind of problem.
We do get some problems with
sites where they've got an
instance of Google Maps
halfway down the page.
If you've got that full width,
someone will be scrolling down
the page, and then they'll
hit their finger on
the Google Maps bit.
And now all their touch events
are going into Google Maps.
It's not a very good
experience.
PAUL KINLAN: So I do have
one question for you.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Go for it.
PAUL KINLAN: If you have a
touchstart on the same range
of elements that you're
in there, does the
behavior match Firefox?
Because it feels like if you're
that you've got a
touchstart events
you'd definitely
want a touchend event.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: If you have
a touchstart event and you
cancel it using
event.preventdefault, then
it's saying that you are
now in charge of
all of those events.
So you will get the
entire sequence.
There is another way
we can fix this.
So let's go back
to the desktop.
PAUL KINLAN: Is this what I
ruined before, by any chance?
No?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yes.
Yes, it is.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, OK.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yes.
This is the one you ruined.
Let's have a look
at number four.
So this is going to
go back to click.
So yeah, we've got that.
Click back there.
But in the HTML we have
a difference.
We've got this meta viewport
here, but it's fixed.
So I'm not going to be
able to pinch zoom.
So let's go back to
the mobile view.
I'm going to go to number six.
I'm not as dexterous
at this distance.
Tell you what, let me just pick
it from the link here.
So we're going for fixed.
PAUL KINLAN: Preparation?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It's brilliant,
isn't it?
All right.
There we go.
So I can't pinch zoom
the viewport.
It's fixed.
But the taps or click, even
just using the click event
which was slow before,
it's now fast.
And that's because we know as
a browser double-tap has no
meaning here.
So we don't have to wait
around for it.
We can take the fast path.
PAUL KINLAN: There's a film
called "Double Tap."
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I've
never seen it.
PAUL KINLAN: It was rubbish.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: OK.
So we do this.
This is something that Chrome
for Android does.
Firefox does it as well.
Unfortunately the other
browsers, including--
PAUL KINLAN: I think we've just
done an article in HTML5
Rocks about the interaction
between touch and click.
And that's one of the bits of
research that we did where we
were testing which browsers when
you had a viewport set
the ability just to have
straight through.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
And as you were saying, this
is one of the things that
we're looking at.
Because having a fixed
viewport is OK.
But it can be nice a nice
accessibility feature you get
for free in the browser to
be able to pinch zoom in.
So it's worth keeping.
So we're looking at ways--
there's a ticket.
We'll post a link to that--
where we're discussing in what
cases can we decide the user's
not going to do a double-tap
here, so we don't have
to wait for it.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
That's right.
So I think on the performance
side this doesn't necessarily
seem performance related.
But it is, right?
It's the first thing that people
encounter when they're
trying to build applications
and sites on mobile.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: This is the
slow bit, right?
It's not slow because the
hardware can't handle it.
It's just slow because of the
way we programmed it, right?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
If you told the network guys
we have a trick that will
shave 300 milliseconds off the
delivery time, they would jump
all over you to get it.
And here we are in mobile with
every click taking that long.
And this is not just
a JavaScript issue.
These examples have all been
JavaScript, but even just a
link on a page is going to
have that 300 millisecond
delay unless you're using
a fixed viewport.
There is a workaround
that works today.
PAUL KINLAN: Is this
the bit now?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: This
is the FT bit.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Actually,
you haven't spoiled
anything after that.
PAUL KINLAN: Well, I can see all
the rest of your script.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah, OK.
Well, we're getting to
the end of this page.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
It might ruin your next
joke, by the way.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh, great.
I nearly did a swear again.
OK.
Let's have a look
on the mobile.
I'm going to switch
over to fastclick.
So this is using a zoomable
viewport, and it's really,
really fast.
So I'll show you what's
happening on the desktop
machine, if we switch
over to that.
So this is using a bit of drop
in JavaScript from the FT.
And if I switch into
the Edit view--
Excellent.
So the difference here is I'm
dumping in a fastclick, which
is a script written by the FT.
We'll put a link to
their GitHub page.
And in JavaScript
it's right here.
This is just this one line
saying I want fastclick to
work for the body.
And what they do is they're
just going to use the
touchstart to touchend events,
but when you let go they're
going to look how far
you traveled while
you were doing that.
And if you've traveled over a
certain distance, they'll go,
ah, that's not a tap
really, is it?
That's not a click.
You were doing a scroll or some
other kind of gesture.
And it's a large script.
There's a lot of edge cases,
a lot of browser bugs that
they've worked around.
So I'm sure they'd agree the
quicker we can kill that
script, the better.
As soon as we can get all
browsers up to date or have a
way that we can work
around this--
this click delay thing--
the better.
But it's really the best we've
got at the moment.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
I think that's touch.
Ah, well, we can deal with the
touch questions when we get
them in the Moderator.
So we want to pull up the link
for the Moderator again, just
so if you want to ask questions
there it is.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That was good.
PAUL KINLAN: Was
it timed well?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That was
a real TV thing.
Pow.
PAUL KINLAN: I want to be
like that guy on YouTube
that you showed me.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Excellent.
We'll put a link to
that as well.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
We should do, actually.
It's pretty good.
Yeah.
So do you want to go on
to your next bit--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: --bearing in mind
that we haven't got a huge
amount of time left.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: We don't?
Or we do?
PAUL KINLAN: Not really.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Not really.
PAUL KINLAN: You can go over.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Ah,
we can go over.
PAUL KINLAN: It's not
like proper TV.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I'm
having good fun.
Are you having fun?
I'm having fun.
PAUL KINLAN: Moderator
says no.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Ah.
Oh, dear.
PAUL KINLAN: Someone did say,
did you just swear?
Or was that a nipple
I just saw?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: There
was a nipple.
There wasn't a swear, though,
so I still keep my job.
That's what's important.
So let's have a look at our
graphical performance demo.
So if we could bring
up the desktop,
if we haven't already.
PAUL KINLAN: You forgot
to [CLICKS FINGERS].
JAKE ARCHIBALD: There we go.
OK.
I'm going to reset that.
This is snakes on a
geometric plane.
PAUL KINLAN: I like that.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It's
good, isn't it?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I'm very, very
pleased with myself.
So as you see, these things
are moving around.
And we're moving around
using a CSS animation.
I'll go into the Edit
screen for this.
Yeah.
So this is the automation
it's using right here.
Let's bump up the size
of it there.
So it's just going around the
top and the left, and it's
going to animate around.
So the performance isn't so
good, even on desktop.
So let's take a look
at it full screen.
I'm going to bring up
Chrome's devtools.
Actually, let's do that now.
So let's bump up the
size there as well.
So I can run this.
This is the timeline.
And what happens here if
I start recording--
PAUL KINLAN: I'm going to say
one thing in a second about
the timeline is that not enough
people use it, and not
enough people know about it.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It's the
best thing we've
added to the Tools.
PAUL KINLAN: Everyone seems to
go to the Heap Profiler and
the CPU Profiler.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Don't do that.
It's rubbish.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
And Paul Lewis, one of our other
colleagues, is really
big on this at the moment.
He's basically saying
all the time that--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It's huge.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
It's big.
It's where it's at.
It's got two turntables
and a microphone.
But anyway, the actual thing
I was going to say was the
biggest problem that we face
are at the moment around
compositor, rendering, and
understanding when the layout
changes inside your app.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: I know you're going
to talk about this now.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Well,
this is it.
You see the problems
we've got here.
PAUL KINLAN: JavaScript
Performance, deal with it when
you get to it.
But you can get a lot out of
this rendering performance.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Exactly.
You can see the problem here
is all we've got these huge
panes operations that
are happening.
But let's take a look at it on
mobile, because that's what
we're here for.
So if we switch over to the
mobile view, I'm going to open
the same thing.
Here we go.
Let's see if I can actually
click a button.
PAUL KINLAN: So you've
prepared devtools?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I haven't
prepared devtools,
but I'm going to.
But we can see on the mobile
view that the performance, it
was bad on desktop, but
it's just really
suffering on mobile.
PAUL KINLAN: And this is what we
were saying at the start is
these devices are probably about
one tenth of the speed
of your normal desktop
machine.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah, yeah.
About that.
They're going to keep getting
faster, but they're always
going to be behind what's
inside your much bigger
desktop machine.
And this is the thing.
Compared to some laptops,
we've both got
high density screens.
But in the normal laptops, your
mobile devices sometimes
have the same amount of pixels,
or near the same
amount of pixels, but much
less hardware driving it.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So I'm
going to connect
devtools up to this.
We're going to do a proper
session on devtools, right?
PAUL KINLAN: We'll probably
rope Addie in
or someone as well.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
I don't want to do that.
So the way you activate devtools
is you connect via
USB with your phone.
If we can bring up the desktop
view, I'll show you.
PAUL KINLAN: Why were you
pinged in google.com?
Did you have network problems
earlier [INAUDIBLE]?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Let's
just go away.
It wasn't that we were panicking
for about 15 minutes
before we started.
PAUL KINLAN: We had no network
And considering this
is a live show, we
had a bit of a crisis.
It was like an adventure.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yes.
It was exactly what I wanted for
my first time doing this.
Nearly swore again.
So if you want to, you put USB
debugging mode on your device.
You connect via USB.
We'll cover this properly
in [INAUDIBLE].
And there's this very intuitive
command you put in.
It's that.
And I don't know about you,
but that was the first--
PAUL KINLAN: You might need to
make it a little bit bigger
for everyone, if you can.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Well, people
just need to look closer.
Get closer to your screens.
PAUL KINLAN: Manual zoom.
Move your head closer
to the screen.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Exactly.
So I don't know about you, but
that was the first word that
came out of my mouth when
I was born, that
adb forward tcp colon.
PAUL KINLAN: Well, I've just
been with it for while now.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Am I allowed
to say colon?
PAUL KINLAN: Colon is fine.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: OK.
That's good.
And then it will say, Error.
Device Not Found.
And this is going to probably
cause me some grief as I start
to do this demo.
Let's see if it's just by
coincidence working.
No, not at all.
That's good.
So what I'm going to do now
is I'm going to unplug it.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And then I'm
going to plug it back in, and
I'm going to see
what that does.
PAUL KINLAN: I have
full faith in you.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That's fine.
Do you know what?
I'm OK.
PAUL KINLAN: I want you to
do more shows later on.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I could start
crying at some point soon.
Let's close Chrome.
PAUL KINLAN: Did you
have Chrome up?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I did
have Chrome up.
PAUL KINLAN: We'll
do ADB Devices.
So we might as well tell
everyone what's happening now.
So this is the you've got
no devices attached.
So the way that you actually
connect devtools to Chrome and
Chrome on devtools is
via the Android
Development Kit at the moment.
And there's a tool inside
the Android
Development Kit called ADB.
Cool.
We've got it working now.
So ADB Devices lists
all of the devices
connected to your machine.
So there might be a
couple of them.
And Jake is going to take the
leap of faith, and it's
worked, I think.
He's run ADB forward.
And ADB forward basically says
we're going to forward a
special port, TCP 922, to all
those connections straight to
this or the host, called local
abstract Chrome devtools.
Now that itself is the devtools
instance running
inside the actual browser.
So what you might notice is
that your devtools inside
Chrome appears different to the
devtools that you'd get
when you debug a device.
And that's because I think the
device that you're on,
the URL says 25.
You're at M25 there, and you
might be on Canary on your
desktop, which is at 26 or 27.
So we're basically forwarding
all the
requests to that device.
And that device is serving up
devtools for us, and then we
go from there.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yep.
PAUL KINLAN: That was actually a
pretty good save, wasn't it?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That was
a really good fill.
I'm very happy about that.
And by the way, the solution
there was to unplug it and
plug it back in, just
the other end of it.
Anyway so what I'm going to do
now is I'm going to pick up
one of these things that's
moving around.
So if we're on the desktop view,
we can see that I've got
this magnifying glass here.
I'm going to click that.
And then I can just tap on the
actual device, if I can catch
one of these snakes,
and it's going to
bring up that element.
It's such a simple thing.
I really like that.
Anyway, what I'm going to
do is a horrible hack.
And I'm going to do webkit
transform and then
translate Z, 0.
And if we watch what happens on
the screen, as you can see
the performance has just
gone much, much better.
In fact, let's not guess
what frame raise it is.
Let's run devtools here.
OK.
We're not perfect.
PAUL KINLAN: You're not at the
full 30 frames a second but--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: No.
It actually visually looks a
little bit faster than that.
And maybe devtools itself
was making it slower.
But the important thing is the
paints have gone, and we've
got compositing instead.
PAUL KINLAN: Can we describe
this [INAUDIBLE]?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: I don't always
pay attention to you.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: OK.
That's fine.
So I'm Barry.
Pleased to meet you.
Welcome.
You're in a studio.
Everything is OK.
The bright lights are OK.
There are three lights.
PAUL KINLAN: No.
I was going to say.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: There
are four lights.
PAUL KINLAN: There's actually
four lights.
That reminds me of the t-shirt
you were looking at before.
Yeah, so this user interface,
I'm pointing at a screen which
you can't see me point
at properly.
But anyway, there's two lines,
60 and 30, and they kind of
vary based on the actual
frame rate that
you're actually getting.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yes.
PAUL KINLAN: Because if you're
getting a really slow frame
rate-- and we've seen
applications that get like a
quarter of a frame a second--
you don't even see the
60 frame a second.
The 30 frame a second
line's there.
But this gives you a great
indication about how fast your
application's running
on the frame rate.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
And the fix we applied there
is by applying hardware
rendering to all of
those objects.
So I'm going to try and explain
difference between
software and hardware rendering
to you really,
really quickly.
So imagine you have
a wall, OK?
A big white wall.
And you're going to do
a painting on it.
PAUL KINLAN: OK.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So you get your
bucket of magenta paint
and your paint brush, and
you draw your shape.
And you stand back, and
you think, wow.
That's brilliant.
Oh, except it's a little bit
too far to the right.
I want to move it to the left.
The problem is you
painted a wall.
PAUL KINLAN: So you're saying
I knock the wall down and
build it up again?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Well, you'll
need to repaint
the wall white again.
Paint the wall white.
PAUL KINLAN: That's actually
even more efficient than what
I was going to do.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Exactly.
Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: So that would
be software rendering.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yes.
And then you paint it again.
PAUL KINLAN: What would my
mechanism be, then, knocking
down the wall?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Knocking down
the well, we're talking IE 5.5
Mac there
PAUL KINLAN: Oh, OK.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I think
that's what they did.
But in hardware rendering, what
you would do is put a
piece of Perspex
over the wall.
PAUL KINLAN: Yep.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: You would
do your painting again.
And then if you wanted to move
it, you would just be able to
move the Perspex.
In fact, you could add multiple
layers of Perspex and
draw stuff on there, and
then moving around
becomes really cheap.
If you wanted to change
something else about it, like
the color or the shape, you've
still got to do some painting,
but moving becomes really,
really cheap.
PAUL KINLAN: Yep.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Excellent.
Did that work?
PAUL KINLAN: That was actually
pretty good.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That
was excellent.
PAUL KINLAN: As you can tell,
I'm not that clever.
I was actually going to
knock a wall down.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Well, we
might do that later on.
We could finish with that.
We could knock this well
down, if you want.
That sounds like a
good way to end.
PAUL KINLAN: With the amount of
trouble we had getting this
place ready first--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That's
true, actually.
Well, yeah.
So if we look at the mobile
phone view, I've put this
button in the middle.
This wasn't a life suggestion.
Go out and do something.
No, this is a button.
And this is going to spend a
second-- there it goes--
worth of JavaScript time
doing a thing.
And you can see there the
animation stops as well.
We can actually improve on
that and improve on the
animation performance as well.
We saw with the code
we had before--
Let's go back to the desktop
view where I can show that.
Let's get ride of devtools.
Come on, JSbin, don't
fail me now.
Right.
So this is the animation
we're doing.
And it's using top and left.
But we could alternatively
animate using
transforms like this.
And if we go to the phone now
or the Nexus, I'm going to
make that happen, if
I can remember how.
Here we go.
Here's our animation name.
And I believe it was
around transform.
PAUL KINLAN: I was laughing at
you earlier, because I was
like, oh, you made a mistake.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
Bug in devtools.
That should be crossed out.
Yep.
This should actually be
webkit-animation-delay, which
is what's being set here, which
is why each circle is
slightly off from
the other one.
And that creates a snake.
So now our performance has
actually gotten much better.
PAUL KINLAN: --on a
geometric plane.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh, so
happy about that.
And if we run devtools
now, look at that.
And in fact, I think
it's actually
at 60 frames a second.
It just gets slower when we're
actually recording.
One of those Heisenbugs.
PAUL KINLAN: Yep.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And we've
got no paints.
We've got no recalculations.
We're just doing composites on
hardware, and that's brilliant.
And furthermore, if I press
this Do Something button,
JavaScript is still going to
block for a second, but the
animation's like don't care.
I'm doing my own things.
Don't care about what
JavaScript's doing.
That's kind of cool.
We'd all like to not care
about JavaScript
every now and then.
PAUL KINLAN: I don't even
care about most
things half the time.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That's
all right.
I don't even care about you.
Nearly did a swear.
OK.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
I think that's kind
of interesting.
I've not seen too many people
use devtools, especially for
performance profiling.
And that's one of the things
that we definitely want to
encourage is people to
use more of devtools.
You get the same kind of
interface exactly against
these devices.
I would say that if you email
me, paulkinlan@google.com, if
you have any ideas about how
you'd like to use devtools and
what you'd like to be able to
actually interact with these
devices better than we can
now, please let us know.
We'll file that feedback
directly to the team.
Yeah.
That's the biggest thing I want
to get out today is we
actually want feedback
when people start
building these things.
And we want you to go and
play with this as well.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
I don't want people to start
thinking of that translate Z
thing as a--
Silver bullet?
Golden bullet?
We'll call it a golden bullet.
PAUL KINLAN: Silverfinger?
Is Goldenfinger silver bullet?
I don't know.
We got into trouble
doing something--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
Let's not.
PAUL KINLAN: Let's
leave this one.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Let's talk
about something else.
PAUL KINLAN: Yep.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: In fact,
I think [INAUDIBLE]--
PAUL KINLAN: It's
not a panacea.
Is that a word?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I don't know.
That's out of my vocabulary.
Can I talk about mobiles?
Is that OK?
Is that OK with you?
PAUL KINLAN: We're actually
running out of time, but I'm
trying to--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Right.
Let me do this demo
really quickly.
PAUL KINLAN: And then we'll
move to questions.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And then we'll
PAUL KINLAN: We need about
10 minutes for questions.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: OK.
That's fine.
I've gone back to the slow
demo on the phone.
And what I'm going to do now is
I'm going to turn off some
of the effects that
are going on here.
So we've got a shadow and
the border radius.
And as we turn those off--
we're just software
rendering now--
things have got lot quicker.
And I'm also going to trigger
something else as well.
I'm going to make the
colors change.
So let's do that.
There we go.
So now it's going to change from
green to yellow just by
changing a class name.
And that's great.
It's not awfully fast,
but it's consistent.
What I'm going to do now is take
one of these boxes, and
I'm going to do the same
hack we did before.
It's really annoying because the
class names are changing.
I can't quite get
a hold of it.
OK.
I'm just going to press here.
Oh, don't do this to me.
There we go.
It's good.
It's fine.
So I'm going to do the same
hack again, translate
Z and down to 0.
And now if we look at the phone,
the performance is
roughly the same as
it was before.
But you can see as it changes
color there's a--
we call it jank, right?--
a jank.
PAUL KINLAN: I used
to call it yank.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It's a yank.
That's racist, man.
Don't.
PAUL KINLAN: It's not.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: You're
getting fired.
I'm still employed.
PAUL KINLAN: Well, I thought it
was like in a lot of places
in Europe they pronounce
the j's y's.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: OK.
All right.
I'm going to move on.
If we have a look in timeline in
devtools in the desktop, we
can see that jank happening
right there.
And we can see what the
result of that is
is all these paints.
And as I was saying before,
because we're actually
changing the appearance of the
element, it's having to go
away and paint every one of
those squares individually and
upload them to the GPU.
And that's really cheap on your
desktop, but it's really
expensive on a mobile.
The Nexus 7 we're demoing on has
quite a good relationship
with the GPU, whereas
phones often don't.
And you can run into
real trouble.
What I'm trying to say is
translate Z is like beer.
It's like having a
bottle of beer.
I don't know about you, but
there are some things I am
better at after a bottle
of beer, things like--
PAUL KINLAN: Darts.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: --talking
to people.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
Dancing.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Dancing, yeah.
Yeah.
But after a few more beers,
I am worse at
them than to start.
I am lying on the floor telling
a fire extinguisher
how pretty its hair is, or
something like that.
And this is how it works.
So your desktop can really
hold its liquor.
It's good at it.
It's being optimized
to do that.
Whereas your phone
is a lightweight.
After a couple of beers, it's
going to start throwing up.
And it's going to be throwing
up GPU memory.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I
could demo that.
Or we're out of time?
PAUL KINLAN: I think
we're out of time.
I think what we should do,
though, is we've got a lot of
questions in the Moderator--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh,
that's good.
PAUL KINLAN: --some of which
I know we can demo.
And we can be a little
bit quicker.
I know there's no one in this
studio after us, so I think we
should be OK.
And if we're not, my colleagues
will ping me and
tell us to get off air.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah,
that's good.
They'll be knocking
at the door.
That's fine.
PAUL KINLAN: Well, they'll
be in America somewhere.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh.
Oh, OK.
How can they use--?
OK.
It doesn't matter.
PAUL KINLAN: It doesn't
matter.
It's the internet.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Wow.
PAUL KINLAN: This cloud
thing, right?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh, is
that our new product?
A transporter?
Is that launching at I/O?
PAUL KINLAN: I did actually say
they'll ping me, not knock
on the door.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh, OK.
PAUL KINLAN: Anyway,
we're wasting time.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Carry on.
PAUL KINLAN: So first and
most popular question,
from Mark J in London.
I don't quite know
Mark J. Do you?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: No.
PAUL KINLAN: Well,
hello, Mark J.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Sorry
if I do know you.
PAUL KINLAN: I'm sorry too.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Has
he put his age?
People should put their
age with questions.
I like it.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
He's 28, from London.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Excellent.
PAUL KINLAN: Will fixed position
always be such a huge
performance killer?
So I know you've done a little
bit of research about this
just today.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
No, it won't.
In fact, let's have a look.
If we go onto the mobile
device, I'm going
to launch BBC News.
And there we go.
OK.
Oh, what's Cameron doing?
Anyway, let's have a look
at devtools as well.
And what I'm going to do is I'm
going to click on this,
and I'm going to get hold
of this masthead here.
There we go.
And what I'm going to
do is I'm going to
make this fixed position.
So fixed and top 0, left 0.
Let's give it width 100%,
because it's not in flow
anymore, and Z index--
What's your favorite
number, Paul?
PAUL KINLAN: 74.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: 74.
PAUL KINLAN: Just ignore
me and put 64 instead.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I hate your
favorite number, so I'm not
going to do it.
So if we have a look at the
mobile device now, I fixed
that masthead at the top.
And really we don't
have too much of a
performance problem at all.
One thing to watch
out for is if--
OK.
The BBC doesn't do
pinch zooming.
In fact, I'm going to make it
do pinch zooming, because
we've got devtools.
PAUL KINLAN: Does this work if
you modify the viewport?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Let's
find out.
This is exciting.
There it is, user-scalable 1.
I don't know what that means.
That doesn't mean anything.
Maximum scale of 1, that's
our problem.
Right.
Let's see if that worked.
Oh, look at it go.
Excellent.
So yeah, using fixed
elements--
Oh, I've clicked on
the link now.
No, no, I haven't.
With pinch zooming, you get a
really behavior with fixed
positioning.
But without it, is it's actually
decently fast.
Yeah, scrolling is
going smoothly.
I think this is a problem
on all the devices.
I think that's what we're
talking about.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: In fact, it's
more of a problem on desktop.
PAUL KINLAN: We actually had a
problem the other week where
we were debugging another app
and fixed position actually
caused a different behavior.
I don't know whether
it was a slow path.
Well, it probably was
a slow path, because
it was a lot slower.
Yeah, it was kind
of interesting.
It caused a whole lot
of repaints that
didn't need to happen.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
At the moment we do a full page
repaint on scroll, which
we're working on fixing.
Fixed elements will go into
their own GPU layer, which is
what's happening on
a mobile already.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
So to answer the question, like
you said before, it's not
always going to be a
performance killer.
We know it is.
And this is the great thing
about open source projects,
like Firefox and Chrome and
others as well is that there
are normally open
bug trackers.
Either submit one.
If it's already submitted by
someone else, it'll be triaged
and merged in with
another issue, so
don't worry about that.
But submit the feedback.
And then that's when we know
fixed position is a critical
problem for developers.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: So yeah, if it
is a problem, let us know.
And the bug trackers are
normally the best way.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
And have a look at the timeline,
because that will
show you that large repaints
are happening.
And any information you
can provider is great.
We'll look into it as well, but
you might be able to find
out that the cause of your
problem is something you can
easily fix.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
Next question.
It's [INAUDIBLE] in England.
Is there a plan for Chrome to
integrate a view which shows
HTML5 exactly how it's processed
on the mobile?
OK.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That
was just words.
PAUL KINLAN: That was me
not reading properly.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh, OK.
Sorry there.
PAUL KINLAN: In iOS,
there's a simulator
which emulates Safari.
It has those differences.
And then the same with
Android emulators.
So this is actually one
of those things that--
Email me, paulkinlan@google.com,
because
I want to find out how people
work on desktop.
Because right now we're finding
that it's not too hard
to connect to a device and
actually do the testing.
But at the same time, we
understand the fact that if
you're on a desktop machine--
Can you actually show up a page
that we can go to to show
one of the little things
that we can do?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: On what?
What do you mean?
PAUL KINLAN: On the desktop.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: On the desktop,
what do you want?
PAUL KINLAN: Devtools.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I phased out.
Devtools.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, on
desktop devtools.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: OK, OK, OK.
PAUL KINLAN: Come on.
Just anywhere.
It's fine.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But I
want to say this--
I can't even spell.
PAUL KINLAN: It's OK.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: OK.
There you go.
Desktop.
PAUL KINLAN: OK.
Now go to Settings, and
then Overrides.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Overrides.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
We can get to User Agent
and Device Metrics.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: So we can
do some things.
Obviously Jake's not clicking
the buttons I
asked him to click.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh, you didn't
say click the buttons.
PAUL KINLAN: I thought you
would have been able to
understand my--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I thought
you were just--
PAUL KINLAN: --motioning.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: --trying
to impress
people with your reading.
PAUL KINLAN: Well, obviously
not, because they can't see
what I'm pointing at on the
screen properly, can they?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh, OK.
Sorry.
PAUL KINLAN: I haven't
got Google Glass.
If I had Google Glass
it'd be awesome.
But essentially what we see is
that we can make the device
metrics to be like a Chrome for
mobile, Chrome for Android
iOS, so you can test it.
However, it doesn't emulate the
viewport, and it doesn't
emulate a whole lot of other
things that you'd expect on
the machine.
And if you talk to the
performance guys, they
actually want you to test--
that was quick--
on the devices, because when
you're thinking about
performance, a lot of the time
it's the GPU characteristics
and a whole lot of other
stuff which might
be causing you problems.
You might think you've done it
quite well on one machine.
You go to your device,
and it's a
completely different profile.
So that's why we're encouraging
people to use the
devtools and actually test on
the devices themselves.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: As you say, the
emulators we have, because
they're actual emulators, they
will accurately show you the
rendering, but they won't
accurately show you the
performance.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: iOS, the dev
simulator is a simulator.
It's using the underlying
rendering in Mac OS.
So your rendering might be
slightly different, and your
performance will be the
performance of your desktop
machine rather than
[INAUDIBLE]
in mobile.
So you need to test them.
And neither of them give you
the same kind of touch
experience that using an
actual device will.
PAUL KINLAN: OK.
We'll do a couple more.
We'll try and get through
a couple more.
A while ago there was a
discussion about the best
approaches for responsive
images, the best way
to defer load in.
Is there a de facto standard
yet, in your opinion?
I No.
There's no de facto standard.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Nah.
PAUL KINLAN: We showed you
in the BBC before.
They do an image replacement
technique with some
JavaScript.
If you actually use the devtools
and go in and inspect
what they do, it's actually
pretty cool.
They work out the viewport size
or the image size and
then work out which ones are
the best ones to display.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: There's
matchMedia.
matchMedia will let you do
a CSS media query test in
JavaScript.
And that's really
useful for that.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
There's a webkit image set
tag which you can use.
And we've got a little hack,
which we'll share later on.
I actually did it on Twitter
the other day where you can
display a two times pixel ratio
image and all those
types of things.
But it's only responsive to
pixel density and not any
other context.
So there is none, and there's
no implementations, and
there's no implementations
of [INAUDIBLE]
yet, which I believe is
the other one as well.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
If you're using CSS backgrounds,
then you can
obviously just use
media queries.
And there's also one for
device-pixel ratio.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
But the problem with
backgrounds, is if you do an
image, for instance, like the
alt tag comes through still
with a lot of other stuff.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: So it's a pain.
I wouldn't recommend using CSS
for content images just
because it's more convenient
to switch them
at different widths.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Look at what
the BBC have done.
PAUL KINLAN: It looks nice.
It looks like the old gifs--
Or gifs?
I don't know.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Gifs.
Definitely gifs.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, gif.
But it's gifs in "Doom,"
not gif.
Anyway, next question.
I use Adobe Edge and weinre to
inspect mobile devices, which
I'm finding useful.
Is it possible to do something
similar in devtools?
Yes.
We've just shown you.
That's the next one.
Currently building an entire
JavaScript app for mobile.
Is mobile generally up to the
process in rendering?
And how can I optimize
for mobile?
From Simon Smith in London.
And I guess his age is 26.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Oh, 26.
PAUL KINLAN: 34?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That's
younger than me.
Well done.
PAUL KINLAN: Anyway.
So I think it all depends on the
operations that you do and
you need to test.
We find that things like
box-shadow that you showed
before and a whole lot of other
stuff can cause issues.
Box-shadow and border-radius
and a couple of other ones.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: And it changes,
because as the browsers update
the performance profiles
change as well.
So you're going to have to keep
testing a little bit.
Process and rendering, yeah,
they're actually pretty good.
If you do it right,
it's pretty good.
But you've got to test,
and you've got
to test on the devices.
I don't think there's any real
way of getting around it,
because devices are different.
Desktops are different.
Tablets are different.
Everything's different.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
JavaScript's not your problem,
really, anymore.
And we heard [INAUDIBLE]
guys are
saying that it's rendering.
Because the JavaScript engines,
even on a mobile
device, are pretty fast,
unless you're doing ray
tracing or trying
to do something
like gzip on the clients.
Yeah, you're going to run
into problems there.
But for general website use,
JavaScript's not you problem.
You might run into rendering,
but devtools will tell you
where the rendering
problems are.
Even something like a
box-shadow, once you've drawn
it, as long as you're not
changing the shape and size of
it, it draws once and it
stays in memory so
it's less smooth scrolling.
PAUL KINLAN: I don't know.
I've seen HTML5 Rocks go slow
because of the scrolling.
I don't know.
It's horses for courses
sometimes.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: And it depends.
Next question, [INAUDIBLE]
in Chile.
Any link for more resources
about mobile
dev with Chrome devtools?
We haven't got anything
dedicated.
We've got developers.googl
e.com/chrome/mobile.
It is literally just the
devtools, so anything that you
do with devtools.
We should probably get some
performance articles written
about how to actually do better
mobile debugging and
everything.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And so have a
look on YouTube for talks by
there's a new young developer
called Paul Irish.
And he's done quite a few
interesting talks about this
stuff, hasn't he?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
And [INAUDIBLE] has as well.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yes.
PAUL KINLAN: So if you
ever see [INAUDIBLE]
ask him to do his Paul
Irish impression.
It's brilliant.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Very,
very good.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
Right.
I want to get one more in.
Patrick H. Lauke.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I
know Patrick.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
And he actually sent
a tweet in before.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Did he?
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
I'm About the other TV presenter
you look like.
And it was rather amusing.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yes.
PAUL KINLAN: So let's
look at this one.
With mobile devices often having
limited memory, care to
comment about not just
compressing and minimizing
files over the AIR gzip but
actually caring about the
deflated file size?
So this for processing
it actually onto
the device in memory.
Can I start with that one?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Whatever,
mate.
Yeah, go on.
PAUL KINLAN: Whatever.
So we've seen this with devices
with different pixel
ratios where a pixel isn't
a pixel anymore.
We've seen that image decode
and resize happens
when you have to--
The image decode always happens,
so the bigger the
image the longer it
takes to decode.
And if it takes it a long time
on a desktop machine to
decode, it's going to take even
longer on a phone or a
tablet to decode.
But we've also seen resizes
happen where if it's not done
at the same DPI, essentially,
as the target device then it
has to do a resize.
So if it knows it's 500 pixels,
it has to actually
double it to 1,000 pixels, in
theory, behind the scenes.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But with all
the different DPIs that we
have on devices now,
it's truly nearly
impossible to avoid.
PAUL KINLAN: Well, you could
have a 1.33333337.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: You could
generate them on the server, I
guess, if it was a problem
on a particular--
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
I know Page Speed tries to do
things like this, the Page
Speed services and everything.
They try and optimize the size
for the container and a whole
load of other stuff--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That
makes sense.
PAUL KINLAN: --and the
device format.
But it's hard man, especially
when you're on the other side
of the server where you don't
quite know the device
characteristics unless you've
got them in a big database.
So how would you
deal with that?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I think it's
down to the browser
developers.
It's not our problem.
Go and fix image resizing.
I know they're looking at it.
And it's something that
will get a lot better.
PAUL KINLAN: I think that's
actually one thing that we
haven't really touched upon
is the time to decode CSS
JavaScript in its raw form.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: So the BBC do
something very interesting,
and it's kind of similar
to something I did
when I was at Lanyrd.
We do a basic feature detect
in the head of the page and
for what we think the site needs
to run the JavaScript
we're running.
So I think for me it was
AppCache and local storage.
For the BBC, I think they look
at JSON and some other stuff.
And if the browser fails those
tests, don't load any
JavaScript.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: And because
the site works without
JavaScript--
The browsers that are going to
fail, though, are going to be
old browsers.
Those old browsers are going
to be slow at pausing
JavaScript.
We saw on old BlackBerrys--
and we weren't running
any scripts, we were
just pausing it--
was causing like a 5 to
10 second delay on
just loading a page.
And caching doesn't
help with that.
That's going to hit
every single page.
So yeah, if you can
conditionally load JavaScript
or conditionally load content
as well, that
works really well.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: But what I would
say don't do is don't
lazyload content on a
mobile device unless
it is a huge chunk.
Because if you're scrolling down
a page and you're loading
in imagery as it appears, that's
quite good on desktops.
But on mobile, if you're
on cellular data--
I guess the same would
apply for a
desktop on cellular data--
the cell falls asleep.
The radio falls asleep.
PAUL KINLAN: I'm falling
asleep right now.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
I'm boring myself, actually.
The cell falls asleep, the radio
falls asleep, and then a
new thing goes to load.
It has to be woken up.
And before it wakes up, it wants
its breakfast, and its
breakfast is your
battery life.
So it does all that, and then
it'll go and download stuff.
So lazyloading can seem like,
yeah, this is going to
speed things up.
Just load stuff when
it's necessary.
On cell data, on mobile
3G, whatever--
PAUL KINLAN: But if you lazyload
at the start of the
page, it's not going to make
that much difference, right?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Start
of the page is fine.
As long as it's roughly
the same time--
PAUL KINLAN: So what you're
saying, though, is anything
with Ajax-based refresh is
going to be potentially a
performance killer or
a battery killer.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
And if you can get away with
sending it all down the wire
to start and it's not too much,
then I would do that.
PAUL KINLAN: It would be
interesting to know well
service and events
work and whether
they keep the battery--
I don't know.
It'd be interesting.
So actually, that's a
good time to finish.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: OK.
PAUL KINLAN: I think.
You just yammered on like
crazy for ages, man.
It was terrible.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I'm
going to the pub.
PAUL KINLAN: So what we're doing
is a series of podcasts.
We're going to have a cycle.
So the next performance
one is going to be
in a couple of weeks.
I know Jake's got a
lot more content.
He prepared it a lot today,
and we ran over.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Join
us next time.
PAUL KINLAN: So we're definitely
going to do another
performance one.
We'd like to hear from you to
understand what kind of things
you want to hear us talk about
around, I suppose, the client
side of the performance.
[INAUDIBLE] is going to talk
about networking and network
performance, and we don't want
to go over that too much.
But building performance user
experiences and user
interfaces, we want to know what
you want to hear about,
the problems that you're having,
so that we can address
them in articles and also in
videos and programs like this.
I think next week is Sam, our
producer, who's actually been
switching all the buttons
for us today and
helping us out loads.
What are we talking about
next week, Sam?
Devtools?
SAM DUTTON: Yeah.
That'll do.
PAUL KINLAN: Devtools or OWP.
We'll send out a
tweet later on.
But it's going to be good, and
we'll ask you for questions
that you want answered
live as well.
And then we'll do this
one again in a
couple of weeks' time.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It's Sam's first
time producing as well
on one of these things.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It's
his first time.
It's my first time.
PAUL KINLAN: You
are producing--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: That's
pretty romantic.
PAUL KINLAN: --next week.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I'm not
producing next week.
PAUL KINLAN: You are.
SAM DUTTON: Oh, yes, you are.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
Next week, if you see it just
changed to a picture of, I
don't know, whatever,
that's Jake.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
So
PAUL KINLAN: Anyway, with that,
I think we're finished.
And we would like
to say goodbye.
Well, I would like
What would you like to say?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Hello.
How's it going?
Do you want to go for a drink?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I think you've
got a great sense of humor.
PAUL KINLAN: OK.
With that, then we'll
see you soon.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Thank
you very much.
PAUL KINLAN: Bye bye.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Bye bye.